the only I really firmly believe you
only have so much bandwidth in a day and
this is coming from a person who pushes
their bandwidth too hard all the time I
think you only have so much in a day and
when you get to a certain state you wind
up diminishing a lot and then I think
you want to diminishing a lot of the
other things that you do like if you if
you have like seven things cooking in
the background on your phone it's not
going to move as fast right Leslie
actually does work that where some
computers but people do that too you
have too many things cooking at the same
time yeah we all do all the time all the
time and then you take 20 minutes of
transcendental meditation and take your
nervous system and put it on restart and
just let it wash out this thing in
hands-free coming out let it wash out 20
minutes okay
because we're all under that all the
time a hundred percent frazzled no
matter how hard you're pushing or just
coasting three o'clock in the afternoon
two o'clock in the afternoon four
o'clock in the afternoon that nervous
system shot right we're all the same how
do you twenty minutes what do you do
talk me through it you take your nervous
system and it's the result of it is you
come out and you've rebooted the system
and you can now have a good part of the
second part of your day do you have a
technique used to use an app do you know
I went to I I went to a transcendental
meditation teacher whoa and in without
the hippie dippie that's the biggest
part of it it literally makes you
realize just what you said we're all
just frazzled and running out of steam
at a certain point yeah your nervous
system is shot all that stuff that's
happened just between seven o'clock and
3 o'clock whatever would happen you're
that nervous system has been dealing
with a ton of stimulus all day long that
meditation gives you a reboot and you
can't it it's it's like a needed thing
that's better than sleep that you you
that you're it actually yearns for hmm
I'm telling you since I really started
dialing it in and and did it it the best
way I can describe it is that it adds
in another four hours to my day whoa
yeah how so because I would just be
limping across the finish line I'd be
exhausted I'd be trying to do and with
motivation and I work really hard I
would push through and get to maybe you
know two hours more of what I needed to
accomplish and you do this effortlessly
without struggle I'm able to just sail
like I did between nine and twelve that
day really yes a hundred percent do you
think by using this practice you're
alleviating tension so you're more
efficient with your energy like what
makes you that's part of it but it
really is it really is taking this
nervous system that is dealing with the
outside world all the time
mm-hmm and just giving it a real
practical way to shut down flatline and
then come back on the grid yeah yeah and
it it like your physical body needs a
rest your things need to be rebooted
your nervous system is kind of this
thing that operates all the time that
we're not really that conscious of we're
not really that aware that how hard it's
working and this is a way to pay
attention to it and give it a chance to
regenerate that's interesting and as
long you been doing this
you know I'm editing it for like since
college just out of reading books and
then probably about three years ago my
friend said who always did
Transcendental Meditation
he said go just see if it dials you in
it actually the stuff you are doing the
way you talk about meditating it sounds
more laborious it sounds like you're
doing too much work just go talk to this
guy and I did for like three four
sessions I went and just talked to this
guy here in LA who's a transcendental
meditation teacher and he just explained
it and dialed me in on it and for the
last three four years I've been just I
haven't missed a day
and three or four years yeah day every
day seven days seven days no cheat day
no cheat day how long no need for cheat
a it's the opposite of what you want
from a cheat day it's like 20 minutes
we're if you can get two in that's the
best if you can get one in the morning
and one in the afternoon then you're
like Superman
Wow but if you can get one in I'm
telling you start to finish how long 20
20 minutes 20 and you do this every day
every day every day maybe that makes
sense man because one of the things that
people remark about you is how easygoing
you are like that like people said dude
I love and tom pappas on your podcast
it's so easy going like that you guys
gel so well together you flow together
yeah it's like you're you're tuned into
we just present together we're just you
know we're both you know yeah you're
kind of not struggling right and that's
what it teaches you you just cut this is
a big Roaring River yeah and it lets you
just kind of go underneath catch your
breath and then come back up into it
yeah do you feel that way when you
exercise do you feel like when you're
exercising you get into like a zone and
you you reset your brain for sure I feel
less I feel less depressed when I
exercise yeah like if I'm gonna funk and
I'm like no and I go for a run I'm like
my days different yeah it's weird it's
almost like that funk is trying to hold
on to control - it's weird yeah so it
gets tricking your brain yeah do you
feel like today let me just put
these goddamn shoes on and go run yeah
you know you feel so good but the
meditation is different the meditation
is like the the run will give me energy
I won't feel so shitty I'm like I'm okay
you know I feel good I feel alive and
whatever but the meditation in a very
subtle way five hours later when you're
faced with a stressful situation you
don't feel as stressed as you normally
would
yeah because it's just you're in your
nervous system which is very powerful
has been rebooted is now able to go and
deal with another situation hmm you
should go see him okay I'll do it I'll
give you the name of the guy he's amazed
I mean he's not amazing it's not a guru
it's not the one sperm guy
it is not about him one minute it's not
about a religion it's not about a people
or a drop of much sperm this guy does
will not give you his sperm he's just
delivering the message of this little
practice which is very it's not
hippie-dippie it's very practical
practical you can use it yeah
it's that's the best part of it um would
you be if you tried the tank before the
foot tank no would you be interested in
doing it you know we have one here you
can use it anytime you want like I would
like to hear what your take on it is
yeah especially yeah especially if you
wanted to practice those techniques in
there yeah I think they would be really
interesting
it's crazy environment man that would be
great yeah you should do it I'll do it
yeah for sure not today I'm drunk yeah
there's a there's also you know there's
a bunch of big places around - there's
the float lab down in Venice and they
have one with it Westwood and then
what's the big place that's in Pasadena
has the biggest one in the world and
people like I'm in like a gym you go
close yeah you sign up go in there and
float past what he's gonna giant just
flew